-Guys, right now, it is time
for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, this week I sent out
the hashtag #IfIWasPresident,
and I asked you guys
to tweet out something funny
or weird things
that you would make happen
if you were elected president.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic.
So thank you all
for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#IfIWasPresident tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This one's from @niko seattle.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
We can get behind that.
-Come on.
-This one's from @Jenna2NYC.
She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
This one's from @mollys mom.
They say...
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes! Exactly right.
This one's from @rstare.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's fun.
This one's --
speaking of mullets,
this one's from
@LongHairedGuy31.
-Oh.
-He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Disgrace!
How dare you!
-Fix it!
-Mm!
How dare you, sir?
-[ Imitates whip cracking ]
Pbht-pbht-pbht-pbht.
[ Smack! ]
[ Laughter ]
I scream!
-I scream!
We all scream for ice cream.
[ Chuckles ]
-It's iced cream.
-I scream.
You scream.
We all scream for ice cream!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Smack! ]
Good day to you, sir.
-Pbht!
-This one is from @geoffjeff--
-Geoffjeff.
-Geoffjeff55. He says...
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
Geoffjeff.
-"What do you want
your username to be?" "Geoff."
-Geoffjeff.
-"Just Geoff?"
-Geoffjeff says it.
No, geoffjeff says it, man.
He means it.
"Just make it more legal."
This one's from @LaceyDawes.
She says...
Yeah.
-Come on!
-What are you supposed to do
with that thing?
This one's from @RUExcite.
They say...
[ Applause ]
-Sure. Sure. Why not?
-This one's from @cvanrysdam.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sure.
-Classic.
-Yeah, classic.
[ Laughs ]
-I've heard that joke.
-Yeah. What?
-Well, how many
hot dogs do you get?
Eight hot dogs, right?
-Ri-- N-- Eh...
-And how many rolls you get?
-Six.
-What's the problem?
-I think it's 10 and 8.
Yeah, I think you get --
-10 rolls?
-10 hot dogs, 8 rolls.
-Yes.
-10 dogs?
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
-So 10 hot dogs.
-10 hot dogs and -- Yeah.
-8 rolls.
-So you got two naked dogs.
-Sure.
-Throw two dogs in one bun.
-Yeah.
-Yeah!
-Hey.
-Oh.
That's right.
-Family show.
Two dogs, one bun. Yeah!
-Don't make it dirty.
I'm talking about hot d--
-Geoffjeff55.
-Come on.
-[ As Donald Duck ]
Oh, goodness.
-Hey, Donald. Donald.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @joncooper23.
He said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, I know that one.
That one there.
[ Laughs ]
Last one's from
@LiterallyHatGuy.
He says...
There you have it.
Those are the
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.